I think if humans were to be extinct
what is the next species that's going to
dominate Earth Dolphins bugs bugs
cockroaches
so NASA is monitoring an asteroid that
could collide with the Earth on
Valentine's Day in 2046. good yay
2046 basically four years man 23 years
20 years asteroids throughout time have
they monitored that might hit the earth
like I feel like that happens though
well that hit the dinosaurs
and then after that there were another
there was one there was one recently
that almost hit us
they shot it with a satellite or
something is that what happened well
that didn't stop it but they did they
did hit it with the satellite to get it
out of the way I could move yeah and it
did right so we're kind of good if we do
that we can just kind of throw a couple
not if it's like massive not if it's
like as big as a [__] State the one
that killed we were talking about this
the other day we talked about this
yesterday how how big an asteroid would
have to be to destroy like destroy the
Earth so the one that the one that
killed the dinosaurs that one [__]
like almost wiped out the Earth yeah so
that was six miles across yeah it it
caused a younger it only needs to be a
mile for it to basically destroy Life as
we know it wow really it basically uh
made a Ice Age happen
um The Cosmic Cloud yeah farming's
[__] and then you know I watched a
Tick-Tock on that on the sizes of the
meteors and like I think the 400
kilometer one would just [__] up Earth
what is that what is that in feet 5K is
3.2 miles so divided so that's about
seven miles I think something like big
couldn't it also do something to the
water where it makes it like it just
burns everything once if it's big enough
everything just gets boil all the water
yeah damn you're we're [__] that's
kind of scary to think it would block
out the Sun and then we would die that's
probably the most unless it's just
insinterate just destroyed the Earth and
split yeah you wouldn't even know that
it happened to just it's like a solar
flare yeah yeah like like um gamma ray
or whatever the [__] that is I feel like
a camera flash maybe don't be like never
have existed yeah crazy I just want to
be a Dragon Ball Z character because we
can all yell solar flare you don't want
to be grilling though but nobody wants
to be Krillin but that's how we go out
baby
so they just found this one two weeks
ago
it's called 2023 DW it was discovered on
February 26th it's now been added to the
risk list risk list and
um it's currently the scariest one
they said that it has a Torino scale
ranking of one meaning it's currently
predicted to pose no unusual level of
danger researchers believe that it has
about a 50 meter diameter about the
length of an Olympic-sized swimming pool
oh [__] but the size uncertainty could
be large so they're not exactly sure
yeah wait so they're like it's a 50
meter asteroid but we actually don't
know that's literally what that said
he's like we're pretty sure it's about
the size of an Olympic swimming pool but
we actually [__] I've never seen the
Olympics
I'm amazed at that sentence yeah I know
right it's one of those Wild Things
current calculations show the chance of
collision is extremely unlikely with no
cause for public attention or public
concern but we're gonna write about but
we're gonna yeah
but check out this article
because it still has a 1 in 607 chance
of hitting the Earth so that's kind of
the like oh I don't know that seems
pretty high in Cosmic terms right yeah I
feel like that's high enough to worry oh
it could happen that's all yeah it could
happen the the chance that it happens is
very small but it could absolutely
happen and it's the newest ad so it is
newsworthy for them right yeah um and
let's send Ben Affleck they're adding it
to the giant list that they have already
oh that they're monitoring what's the
closest one so far that none of them the
which ones like out of that list I think
one just passed us yeah yeah like Joe
was saying there was one that just
passed us that they were tracking for a
while too dang nice that happened during
cold like lockdown where would it hit do
they know I also think no yeah it
doesn't say the satellite that they shot
at it the most recent one it's like it
was really small and then they just
because in speed or in space it just
keeps gaining speed so it's practically
like a bullet and yeah alter the course
a little bit and then what are they what
are they shooting at it exactly I don't
know like a laser expensive material
it's just a satellite I guess I don't
know what it's made of what if it's just
shooting a gun it's just it's just old
Tire Parts the bow and arrow
that's the landfill they're like what do
we do with this let's just use it as a
bullet there was like a huge one like a
like a size of an Olympic swimming pool
like they could probably fire something
out into space that could also alter
that course the size of two swimming
pools so what they're talking about what
they're talking about is called Dart
right it was this um a Chevy Dart job of
it was was the launch of Chevy darts
we're just gonna launch the shittiest
card
PT Cruisers up there they're like you
know how you have bad credit you're
driving a PT Cruiser send them out so
what's cool you can actually see the
debris that was ejected from the
asteroid when the dart hit right when
the Chevy Dart hit stupid so dumb um the
debris blasted from the surface
of dimorphous 285 hours after the
asteroid was intentionally impacted and
then the course was changed
crazy Betty's sick wow what else do you
would you say about it again [__] I
only know my arm getting references yeah
well I said just send Ben Affleck up
there space is crazy space is wild you
know there you go what's the coolest
thing that could happen if an asteroid
hit the earth I mean a lot of people
afterwards we just kick our feet up I
think if humans were to be extinct what
is the next species that's gonna
dominate Earth Dolphins bugs bugs
cockroaches
no there's there was there was a show on
[__] the History Channel or Discovery
Channel where they talk about like you
know 100 years from now like what would
happen so they do Europe and they talk
about oh the Eiffel Tower just collapse
but one of the things is all of the
royal dogs
would be okay because they'd be in
Buckingham Palace like the humans would
die and then like all of the food
they just they just assume humans
disappear they don't assume like
something catastrophic happens they just
say humans just disappear yeah and so
like all the food so like these dogs
would be the only dogs that would have
resources after a certain while
but there's no one to say good boy good
girl yeah so they were talking about
like the super corgis like super corgis
because all the dogs in the Royal then
that food would eventually run out and
then they have to eat each other yeah
and then you get you get like an alpha
small to turn the knob
they can't open the boy or the worst boy
the baddest boy that's it we should make
it I don't think it'll do very well
if you guys I mean you know that the way
we monitor the sky right now is
extremely inefficient right like they
just got kind of good at it really but
you can still find out like is this the
old guy yeah just I can see because of
the way that we look at the sky it's
almost like looking at a [__] pin
prick like when you're looking at a
swimming oh right right yeah so we could
like there is a chance right that we
hear right now it's like oh there's an
asteroid head right now what do you do
right because you can't see everything
no taking Joe's backpack and I'm running
now that we know about Joe's backpack
yeah it's good we all vote each other
for it would you rather be like let's
say that was happening would you rather
be the guy on Earth or the guy in like a
space station watching it happen oh [__]
I'd rather be on earth dude so you'd
rather just die what are we supposed to
do we can't go anywhere
the dude on Space Station's got to take
a [__] in space for the rest of his life
and just watch he's like watch everyone
die dying in space would probably be the
one dude's lonely as hell think about
like the traffic
like in LA for example trying to go
anywhere you give me [__] yeah you have
to just stay where you're at you need a
helicopter I would say just like spend
the last moments with your loved ones
well you can't
half the traffic that's why we're gonna
be here we'll do our last Jake this is
I'm talking about episode live just it
will just upload it the Internet won't
be there yes we could just go live yeah
yeah everyone go live all right here it
comes we'll really see what all the
YouTubers are made of in that moment see
like where everyone's alliances lie that
would be one time where like it's not on
a clickbait headline
end of the world question mark it's like
yeah you see like Logan Paul like just
be like what do we do like by Prime
so yeah dude gotta make that money
anyone want to buy anyone want to buy
the Charizard card I think I'd go to
7-Eleven what would you do buy some
cookies and just eat whatever guilt-free
there you go but you choose 7-Eleven
because it's down the street stop one
that's the normal stuff yeah dude
take a bet take a bath in there in their
bra that means the Shabu waiters like I
would [__] serve
they're just cotton super thin like look
at it you can I can see I could see the
asteroid there's always a guy like that
in those movies too they're like why are
you still here and he's like this is
all I know they're just spinning Bill
Gogi on Chopsticks like come that's kind
of cool though
that guy's a deep mother he's dedicated
yeah that's a good way to dude honor to
your craft yeah that's the only way to
go out we just start dancing yeah dude
whoa no how what is the world Guinness
book of world record for longest head
spin do you know yeah have you like
looked it up the dude who who has
records in my crew oh really oh so easy
so we'll just get him and just be like
you're beating it you've got whatever
clock sticking you better you better do
it do you think he'd get pissed if you
beat him there's no way okay the most
I've ever done personally he's probably
like in the 20s you've done 20 minute
head spin no 20 rotations oh he's in the
200 somethings oh [__] how long is that
that's a pretty long time he can he can
spin for hours what and is it just is
you just from the whipping is it like a
pirouette does how does that work he
just has if you look at his body it just
looks perfect for Speed
do you have to do like open clothes like
uh figure skaters to get the the the
yeah he could just go forever he has
this like amazing like centrifugal like
yeah like sense yeah and he doesn't get
dizzy yeah really does he wear a beanie
he did a he did like a there's a
National Geographic special on just him
that they did to figure out why he he's
a superhero was it the superhero you
know the inner ear fluid that yeah of
course yeah it doesn't go off balance so
he just doesn't get dizzy so even if he
like gets drunk he's not stumbling or
anything that's it
[Music]
foreign